Welcome to the Adaptive
Immunity 1 and 2 lecture and
this lecture will expand
on the Adaptive Immunity
lecture that we had in the
fall and flesh out more the
roles of different components
of adaptive immunity.
The objective of this
session is to outline first
and talk about the
structure of immunoglobulins
and their subtypes and
explain the role of MHC
molecules both 1 and 2, T
cell receptor and B cell
receptor, and their role
in immunity. We'll talk
about how different
lymphocytes are activated.
We will compare and contrast
the four different types
of hypersensitivity
reactions. We'll also compare
and contrast your modal
and some mediate immune
response and the roles of T
helper 1, T helper 2, and T
helper 17 cells. And then
we'll finalize this lecture
by discussing how we
regulate the immune response.
In this slide let's
talk a little bit
briefly about each
of the molecules
that we see commonly in that
immune response. Of course
things like immunoglobulins
which are also referred
to as antibodies antibodies
in the globulin same term.
Don't forget that the B
-sub receptor is also an
immunoglobulin, specifically
immunoglobulin D. Now we'll
talk about major
histocompatibility molecules, MHCs.
There's three different
types, one, two, and three,
and we'll discuss those.
We'll also talk about the
T-cell receptor and its
important interaction.
And then we'll talk about
different chemicals and
molecules that are involved
in cellular interaction,
pedocrine interaction
within the immune response.
Important molecules like
cytokines, which we have discussed,
and we'll talk more about
those and we talk about
chemokines and how they
attract phagocytes different
populations of lymphocytes
to the infected area or
inflamed area we discussed
adhesion molecules and we also
seen and talked about cd
molecules or cluster of
differentiation molecules which
we discussed last semester
more specifically during
the histology of the immune
response but cd molecules
plays very important roles
a lot of them are receptors
they can help us distinguish
between different white
blood cells and sometimes
they have a role like cd47
in protecting cells from
being phagocytized or cd59
which protects from complement
system let's start out by
talking about immunoglobulins
immunoglobulins are
basically soluble proteins
that are usually found in
serum but in other locations
too as we will discuss the
term they they're said to
be responsible for what's
called the humoral immune
response and the word humor
actually means soluble or
can dissolve and that's where
that came from immunoglobulins
have specific affinity
and they bind specifically
to an epitope on an antigen
so an antigen typically
is a large foreign substance.
It's in any foreign
substance that elicits any
response. But antigens typically
have many different
epitopes and these epitopes
can all potentially bind to
antibodies. Just like the
figure you see on the right
side here, there's one
antigen with multiple epitopes
that cannot be displayed.
Antibodies or immunoglobulins
are responsible for
what's called antigen
antibody reactions. We'll talk
about those things like
immobilizing an antigen,
sometimes by cross
-linking it, neutralizing
it, preventing it
from doing its job or
upsliding it, tagging
it for destruction.
Let's discuss the four
different types of antigen
antibody reactions that we
typically see. The first
one's called the precipitant
reaction. This is actually
kind of an older type of
laboratory technique that
people used to use where
you would add equal amount
or different amounts of
antibody and antigen and you
keep doing that till you
finally get to the point
where you have almost equal
altitude and then when
that happens the complex
gets large enough that they
actually precipitate so
this used to be the way one
of the old ways to actually
determine the concentration
of antibodies to figure
out how much a person has
antibodies now we have of
course different techniques
and better techniques
that can help us with that
other injured antibody
reactions we see are
agglutination or sometimes
called cross-linking people
sometimes call it clumping
but be careful that terms
not very accurate so an
agglutinated reaction
typically involves the large
antibodies, IgM or IgA.
They have to be, you know,
the IgM is a pentamer,
IgG, I'm sorry, IgA is
a dimer, and they have
the ability to bind,
basically, when they bind to
epitopes on different
antigens, they bring these
antigens together.
There's a picture on the
right side there top showing
you how, for example,
agglutination reactions
can cross-link red blood
cells, and then you can
actually see a precipitate.
That's how we do an typing
of blood when you add
MTA, MTAB and figure out
the person's blood type,
basically you see an actual
agglutination reaction
that you can use in concede
with your ***** eye.
Neutralization mainly
occurs by IgG but it can
also be done by IgA and
they're both effective
at it and that basically
they bind to a molecule
and neutralize it such
as a virus preventing
it from binding to our
receptors for example.
a lot of times this is
kind of like the gold
of immunity you've probably
heard of neutralizing
antibodies and so these
are antibodies that
would neutralize other
substances like viruses
and last but not least
antibody reactions may involve
opsonization in this
case the antibody is not
neutralizing the substance or
agglutinating it but instead
tagging it to be destroyed
in my other cell that's
referred to as opsonization
so this is membranes
was similar to how complement
is very effective at
doing that, that we talked
about in the last lecture.
Let's discuss the structure
of immunoglobulins, organ
or antibodies. All immunoglobulins
are made out of four
large polypeptides. There
are two pretty big ones
and those are called the heavy
chain and two lighter ones
which are called the
light chains and those are
typically joined by disulfide
bonds based on the antibody
heavy chain we actually
have five different antibody
isotypes so these are
the antibody isotypes you
see right here mu gamma
alpha delta and epsilon
and those correspond
different type of antibodies.
For example, mu is IgM,
gamma is IgG, alpha
is IgA, delta is IgD,
and epsilon is IgE.
There's also one
convenient way to set to
distinguish among
antibodies or different
sections of the antibody
molecule is by digesting it
with the protease called
Papin. Papin digestion splits
the antibody into the FAV
portion and that's the portion
that has the antibody
binding fragment and the FC
portion which contains the
constant region so what's
the constant region versus
the antibody binding fragment
so if you see the antibody
also has what's called
the variable region that's
the region basically on on
top where the light chain is
and the heavy chain that's
where it binds the epitope
but on the other hand the
big chunk of that heavy chain
is usually mostly constant
it doesn't really change
between antibody another
unless it's a different ice
type but the variable origin
always changes because
that's gonna depend on the
epitope it it binds to it
so anyway the papindigestion
sometimes you know gives us
these feb and fd portions
and you when we talk about
phagocytes binding to the
FC portion, we're referring
to phagocytes binding to
the to the constant region
basically of the antibody.
Let's talk about
different antibodies.
So the first one we'll
talk about is IgM. So
IgM is the Mu isotype,
like we discussed
before, as you can see on
the figure on the right
side. It's a pentamer,
it's a five-membered
structure,
all joined by disulfide
bonds. So it's the
largest antibody. It's
secreted in plasma
and usually secreted
as part of the
primary adaptive immune
response. Afterwards
IgM usually wanes
and IgG take place.
Sometimes we find
IgM as a monomer on
B cell surface, but
that's more rare.
This is the antibody
responsible for the egg
alternation reaction
because it has the ability
to cross-link multiple
antigens and has also
the ability to immobilize
them because once
cross-linking of these
antigens take place in
this large antibody, the
complex becomes so big
that it cannot really
move properly in the body.
It's also very good at
complement fixation because of
the multiple FC fragments
you know this case five and
it makes sense because it's
one of the first antibodies
that are made so it's good
to have complement working
that way and of course
because of its huge size it
cannot cross the placenta
next antibody we'll talk about
is IGD which is the isotype
delta this is a monomeric
antibody and it's predominantly
the B cell receptor of
course it's important
because that's how the b cell
recognizes an epitope and this
is how the antigen selects
for the correct b cells
by specifically binding to
these structural antibodies
igd and then of course they
differentiate the plasma
cells and make the same exact
type of antibody. IgM first,
then an IgG afterwards.
IgG, or crizotype
gamma, is probably
the most common
antibody in serum.
It's a monomer usually,
can be found both on
the surface of B cells,
but it's mostly secreted.
It is the second
antibody that's released
during the adaptomy response,
so that would be your
secondary, so you have
the primary immune
response, but then the
secondary immune response,
IgG starts to rise, has
the ability to neutralize,
has the ability to
opsonize and activate
complement. It's also involved
in some hypersensitivity
reaction and antibody
-dependent cell
mediated cytotoxicity.
So basically when IgG can
actually bind to a certain
cell, it can label it
for killing. And we'll
talk about that reaction
at the end of this
lecture. It's also
the antibody that
crosses the placenta.
Again, very versatile,
very important antibody,
and typically when it's
detected it suggests that
immunity has been established
through an infection.
IGA, the isotype alpha,
is a monomer also found in
serum but it's also found
as a dimer in secretions
throughout the body like
milk, tears, saliva,
mucous membranes, of course
a part of the malt, the
mucosal associated lymphoid
tissue. It's the most
antibody produced daily
constantly being shed
and of course very important
in protecting us from
pathogens, has the ability to
neutralize, block
viral entry, etc.
IGE with the isotype
epsilon is actually the
lowest one in serum.
It's a monomer and it's
typically absorbed on
mast cells in eosinophils
and it causes the
release of histamine and
also activates eosinophils
to attack worms.
So in that regard it's
effective but it's
also involved in allergic
reactions are basically
type 1 hypersensitivities,
specifically
the immediate type,
also sometimes called.
And we'll discuss these
and we discussed those
last semester too, so
we'll be able to go back
and revisit this topic
because of its importance.
We have discussed and
talked a little bit about
what's called antibody
-dependent cell mediated
cytotoxicity. This can
happen, by the way,
predominantly by IgG, but
IgM can also do this too,
but to a lesser extent.
And so typically antibody
can tag bacteria, parasites,
worms, etc., which can
attract natural killer cells.
And we talked about natural
killer cells in the last
lecture, the innate, and
how they display both CAR
and CAR receptors to detect
and be able to kill pathogens
or our own cells if they
are infected by a virus.
and eosinofils can also
mediate interaction. This is
an important mechanism to
clear pathogens of our body.
In the next three slides
we're going to discuss the
hypersensitivities that are
antibody mediated, basically
type 1, type 2 and type
3. Type 4 we'll talk later
because type 4 is not antibody
mediated as you already
know, it's cell mediated.
So that we'll discuss later.
So hypersensitivities as
sometimes we collectively
call them in layman words
other allergies but the word
hypersensitivity as i
emphasize to you guys is the
correct immunological and
medical term but of course
as you talk to patients
you have to explain it in
terms of allergies either way
type one is also sometimes
called immediate
hypersensitivity and that term
comes because it can happen
almost instantly once the
person has been primed
already. It's IgE mediated,
mainly IgE sensitized, and
it detects an epitope on
an allergen and then mast
cells and piocerophils are
activated which produce
tons of histamine and we end
up with the classical
reactions you know anaphylaxis
could possibly become
anaphylaxis but not always.
And that's a that's a type
1 hypersensitivity. Again,
I have to be primed
which means there
needs to be memory
cells to produce IgE.
You just cannot be
from the first time.
So we've discussed how antibody
-dependent cell mediated
cytotoxicity, especially
directed against infected
cells, bacteria and
parasites, is very effective
and part of the normal
neural response. But at the
same time it can develop
into a hypersensitivity, a
type 2 hypersensitivity if
it's directed at our own
healthy cells. And so
typically it's an IgM-IgG
interaction, especially towards
cell membranes or matrix,
usually complement natural
killer cells involved.
Examples of that would
be like a hemolytic
anemia that happens
from mismatch.
Somebody given a transfusion,
let's say, which is
an incompatible blood
type, you end up binding of
antibodies to like basement
membranes resulting in
inflammation and death and
necrosis and tissue injury.
Another example
of that is Gravis
disease and last
thing is Gravis.
Also rheumatic
fever is considered
a type 2 hypersensitivity.
Type 3 hypersensitivity
is typically when we have
a lot of immune complexes
that are circulating.
Typically lots of antigen
-antibody complexes. A lot of
times it's pretty much
mediated by IgG and these
complexes can deposit in blood
vessels causing vasculitis.
These type of reactions
can be either localized and
in that case it's referred
to as Arthas reaction.
Usually you have like an
abscess or necrotizing
vasculitis or it can be a
systemic type of reaction in the
case of systemic it's
usually referred to as serum
sickness this terminology
dates back to the times when
people used to use convalescent
plasma which is you
know currently used for
sometimes COVID treatment and
these plasmas can cause a
reaction usually like for
example taking horse serum
injecting into a human we end
up reacting to the foreign
serum or foreign antibodies,
like antibodies for another
animal, and that results
in serum sickness. So again,
it could be exogenous,
non-human antibodies, or
drug-induced, like penicillin
can do this, or endogenous,
like systemic lupus,
erythromatosis, or
sometimes it's called lupus.
We just discussed
the antibody-mediated
hypersensitivities. There's
still one more type, type 4
which is cell mediated
and we'll talk about that
after we discuss the cell
mediating your response.
We'll switch gears a
little bit and talk about
MHC molecules and the
role in adaptive immunity.
So MHC molecules are
basically the same terminology
as human leukocyte
antigen, or at least in
humans we call them human
leukocyte antigens. MHC
molecules are found in
all animals including
humans. There are mainly
three types, MHC class 1,
MHC class 2, and MHC
class 3. The class 3
are basically the
complement. Code for some
of the complement
components are focused on
the B-more in MHC class
1 and MHC class 2.
MHC class 1 is found
on all nucleated cells,
for example. So you don't
see them on red blood
cells because red blood
cells are not nucleated,
but all cells with the
nuclei in the body will have
MHC class 1. So it's easy
to remember that, they
were everywhere basically
all of our cells have
to display msc class one
basically to report whether
they're not uh are viral
infected or they have
tumors or to simply make
sure that they are self
so there's one way we can
recognize that ours this
is our cell versus this
is a foreign substance
again coded by hla a b z
um you know there's almost
like a hundred alleles
on each locus gives rise
to many different combinations
and it is important
when we have transplants
or from one person to
another let's say organ
that the MHCs especially the
MHC1s are compatible or
at least as compatible as
they can be to to prevent
you know graft rejection.
MHC class IIs on the
other hand are only and
mainly expressed on
antigen presenting cells
you know there would
be some like dendritic
cells and macrophages,
but you'll only
find them, you'll also
find them on B cells,
some activated T cells,
and if you remember these
specialized epithelial,
thymic epithelial cells,
that actually involved
in, you know, negative and
positive selection or
education of thymocytes,
if you recall from the
histology lecture of last
semester. Again, what do
those do? They are involved in
antigen presentation. Very
important step. You cannot
activate the adaptive immune
response or specifically
the T helper cell without
an antigen presenting cell
presenting that foreign
antigen on the MHC class 2.
So we have discussed the
MHC class 1 molecule. Let's
turn and talk a little bit
about the T cell receptor.
A very important receptor,
of course, it's crucial for
T cell recognition,
interaction with antigen,
activation. The T cell
receptor is a heterodimer.
It's made up of two
molecules that are different.
The most common type of T
cell receptor is the alpha
beta type. There's also the
lesser common gamma delta.
Usually the T cell receptor
is not alone on the surface.
It's typically associated
with the CD3 and costage
differentiation, which helps
with signal transduction.
Very important thing
about the T cell receptor
is that it's restricted
to MHC. It has to bind
fragments on either MHC
class 1 or MHC class
2. Without that, there's
really no interaction.
So a T cell receptor cannot
engage antigen by itself.
If it's the... and
again, And in addition to
that, there are also
either a CD4 receptor, and
that's in the case of T
helper cells, or a CD8
receptor, that is in the
case of T cytotoxic cells.
So typically on the surface
of a T cell, you would see
T cell receptor, CD3, and
either CD4 and CD8, and
those would interact with
either MHC class 1 or MHC class
2. If it's a CD8 T-tyotoxic,
that's probably MHC
class 1. and if it's a t
-helper it's a CD4 MHC class 2.
We talked about these cellular
interactions, we
talked about cytokines,
basically those are low
molecular weight soluble
proteins which act as
messengers and they're prominent
in the most common way
by which different cells
communicate in our body.
We talked about chemokines,
they're basically cytokines
that are chemo-attractant,
they basically they allow
phagocytes to home in and
other locusites to a different
site of inflammation.
We talked a little bit
about integrins and
selectins and their
role in allowing
phagocytes to get to the
site they need to do.
And we also talked
about CD molecules
in a cluster differentiation.
And a lot of times they
can help us identify
different cells, they can
indicate the function.
There's been lots of CD
molecules identified.
and of course the most
common ones are like CD3,
CD4, CD8, and they were
common ones we just
discussed last semester,
they were in a table,
make sure you hear those,
I remember you knew
some of them, especially
the ones that identify
certain type of cells.
Next we're going to talk
about how the adaptive
immune response is
activated. So that immune
response mainly is activated
through the activation
of T helper cells.
That process is a very
time consuming event
with a lot of checks and
balances. It takes a good
week and a half for that
process to take place
and that's intentional.
You don't want the immune
response or especially that
immune response to just
be activated at a whim. It
really has to take a lot
and ensure that you've
exhausted all other potential
issues such as innate immunity
maybe the pathogen has
been resolved by them so
and you know as we discussed
the main cell that controls
and regulates the adaptive
immune response whether
it may be the hemodal or
the cell mediated is the t
helper cell and all the
subsets that come with that
and remember MHC class
one is required sorry one
and two is required for
lymphocyte activation
because the T cell
receptor is MHC
restricted so
there's no activation
of any T cell
simply by itself. It
has to be through
a MHC molecule.
Let's discuss briefly
MHC class 2 presentation
and we'll discuss
MHC 1 presentation.
So with MHC class 2, remember
MHC molecules are restricted
to antigen presenting
cells only and you know B
cells have them too and
few T cells have them but
predominantly it's dendritic
cells and macrophages dendritic
cells seem to be the most
important regard to antigen
presentation they play the
largest role they act as
sentinels by being in lymph
nodes constantly monitoring
lymph for the presence of
anything funny typically
dendritic cells are able
to phagocytize that engine.
It's an actin-dependent.
When it's processed inside
the alendritic cells,
you know, basically
phagosomes use the lysosome.
You chop it to pieces and
then you take that antigen
and fuse it with MHC
class 2 molecule displayed
on the cell surface which
then it can interact
with the proper, in this
case, T helper cell, which
is RCD4 positive cells.
MSC class 2 can display
both self and non-self
and sometimes displaying
self can lead to
tolerance. So remember
we discussed that earlier
last semester where MSC
class 2 usually is displayed
for T cells to help
them with selection and
to mature T cells. and,
of course, displaying
of foreign antigens so
you can activate them.
MFD class 1 presentation is
processed differently. MFD
class 1 is found in all
nucleated cells in the body.
Basically, if there's
an inside antigen or if
there's a foreign substance
inside the cell or
the cell is a tumorous
cell, any cell in our body
will basically take that
intracetral antigen,
which is typically tagged
with ubiquitin or the
protein of ubiquitin. this
will allow the proteasomes
inside the cell to destroy
it or chop it to pieces
which is then sent to
the endoplasma reticulum
and then the Golgi and
then in the Golgi these
antigens are then combined
with MHC class 1 and then
they are displayed on the
cell surface hoping for
of course a T-cell toxic
cell which is a big positive
to recognize it and if it
is let's say a protein,
then death of that cell
will incur afterwards.
As we've said several times
now, the T helper cell
is really the pivotal
cell when it comes to the
adaptive immune response.
Now this is the reason
like a disease like HIV that
targets the helper cells
basically wipes out
all the adaptive immune
response. So T helper cells,
also known as CD4 positive
cells, only recognize
MHC2 associated antigens.
They form the interaction
between the naive T
helper cell and the endogen
presenting cell like
a dendritic cell is referred
to as the immunological
synapse. A picture of
that is seen on the
side here showing how
the different receptor
interaction everything that's
involved including cell
adhesion molecules in
addition to CD3 and CD28
CD80 co-stimulatory signal.
So again, notice here
there's the T cell
receptor, usually the
alpha-beta kind binding to
the MHC class II with
an end in the middle,
supporting that as a CD4
receptor, and in addition
to that, CD3 or two CD3
receptors are associated
with T cell receptor, and
this This requires the co
-stimulatory signal. The
co-stimulatory, the CD28,
results in stabilization
of that synapse.
Without that, you're gonna
have very weak interaction
and probably abortion
of that interaction
and that activation,
or energy, basically.
In some cases, it can
lead to apoptosis, too.
Remember, energy for
a T-cell, meaning if
a T-cell becomes numb,
it does no longer
recognize that antigen,
does not react.
The first contact of the
foreign substance with the
T-cell will help prime it,
and that, of course, involves
the production of
cytokines. Depending on the
cytokine, we'll end up with
different populations of T
-cells. The original progenitor
T-cell becomes then an
active T-cell, and it can
go different ways. It can
become a Th1, Th2, or Th17,
or also the other Th helper
cells that we typically
don't discuss, since there's
at least like nine of
them. But depending on the
cytokine profile, which
they will receive from the
antigen presenting cell, they
will differentiate into these
different kinds. A lot of
times differentiating into
one kind inhibits differentiation
of the other kind.
And even when that happens,
this does not mean that
you're always going to
have that species of cell.
These subtypes may change.
But so let's say if the
antigen presenting cell produces
interferon gamma. Typically
the naive T helper cell
will differentiate into
TH1. If it's IL-4, IL-10,
it'll differentiate to TH2.
If it's interleukin-6 or
transforming growth factor
beta, that's T helper 17.
And these cytokines inhibit
the other type of cells.
For example, interferon
gamma inhibits differentiation
of T helper 2 cells.
And you know, there's been
recently more recognition
of the presence of what's
called memory T cells which
have high expression of
the core receptor and those
seem to last in the body and
confirm immunity down the
road similar to memory B
cells which make antibodies.
Let's discuss the T cytotoxic
cell activation or CD8 cell.
So CD8 cells will recognize
antigenal MHC class 1. This
interaction results in them
in expressing IL-2 receptor
and then once they interact
with the T helper 1
cell, T helper 1 cells will
produce IL-2 which then binds
the IL-2 receptor that's
been overexpressed in CD8 and
this helps with activation
of that T cytotoxic cell.
When that occurs T
cytotoxic cells will then
engage Hd antigen on
different cells. Usually these
are intracellular antigens
and as a result they
recognize that cell as
being affected. They will
produce perforins which
are proteins that poke
holes in that membrane
of that cell and also
produce granzymes which
actually induce apoptosis.
And this is how a T
cytotoxic cell becomes
effectively activated. these
are toxic cells can also
engage you know infected
cells by themselves too
without the need for a T
helper one cell but that
type of side engagement
so to speak is really much
weaker and not as effective
as within the absence
of TH1 activation and
interleukin 2 release let's
talk about B cell activation
B cell activation similar
to T cell toxic cell activation
can recognize antigen
in the association of MHC
class 2 or the T helper cell
or without it. But usually
it's much more effective
in the presence of a TH2 or
a TH17 cell. So typically
what happens is the B cell
receptor will recognize the
antigen using its actual
B cell receptor and then
results in endocytosis of that
antigen and then the antigen
is presented in MHC to a
CD4 positive cell and this
happens with T dependent
antigens which are typically
proteins because proteins
can be processed that way.
Again the B cell can engage
either a TH2 or a TH17
depending on the type of
pathogen. This results
in either reproduction
of IL-4 in the case of
TH2 or IL-6, which is the
case of TH17, and that
will cause the B cell
to become active and
differentiate to a plasma
cell and produce antibodies.
IL, sorry, an immunoglobulin
E or IgE if it's
TH2 or IgG or IgM if it's
TH17. And some of those
differentiated B cells
will become memory cells,
so they can engage with
antigen down the road.
So this is in the case of
this is the most common
type of antigens, protein
antigens, which are also
referred to as T-dependent
antigens. But B cells can
also engage what's called
T-independent antigens. A
lot of these are polysaccharides
or lipid in nature.
So those antigens are not
typically processed the
same way inside cells and
so but at the same time we
have to respond to them
because they are foreign
antigens. So how do we do
that? We have basically B cells
that can do without the
help of T helper cells,
and those are referred to
as T independent antigens.
They can be either subdivided
the T1 or T2. The T1s are
pretty much like LPS.
These are very effective,
what's called B cell
mitogens. These are
super activator of B cells.
They can activate them
by binding to receptors
other than the B cell
receptor and they're
very strong activators.
And then we have T2
antigens and those are the
polysaccharides or the lipids
and they basically only stimulate
mature B cells. And to clear
those antigens of course
you also need complement
and so on to help. So those
would be T2 and T should
be something like capsules.
So terminology
we've used many times
before. We basically divide
the adaptive immune
response into two arms,
the heomodal and the
cell mediated. The cell
mediated immune response
is usually specifically
designed to address
intracellular pathogens.
Pathogens basically or
whenever the pathogen is
found inside the cell and
those are also responsible
for type 4 hypersensitivities
while the hemoral
immune response mediates
itself through the production
of antibodies and that's
predominantly to against
exocerebral pathogens or
whatever that pathogen
is on the outside of
the cell and those are
responsible like we talked
already and discussed in this
lecture for type 1, 2
and 3 hypersensitivities.
Now this distinction
between exocerebral pathogen
intercellular pathogen is
important but sometimes
you heard me say if
it's on the outside if
it's on the inside and
what i mean by that is
viruses by definition are
intercellular pathogens
but when a virus kills a
cell and comes to the outside
it has to go in mind to
another cell in that transition
it is on the outside so
that means that virus can
be blocked by an antibody
so in other words even
classic intercellular pathogens
at some point of their
life cycle they spend time
outside in the excess cellular
space and then you they
could be targeted that way
um you know and the so
the cell mediated immune
response that's your
th1 cells and your
immoral immune response
that is our th2 th17 so
so far we have discussed
type 1 type 2 and type
uh 3 hypersensitivities
let's discuss type 4
hypersensitivities also used
to be called delayed type
hypersensitivity and the reason
for that it usually comes 48 to
72 hours after encountering
antigen at any given time
now this is a th1 a
macrophage induced type of
inflammation kind of cell
mediated because it does require
th1 cells it can be either a
result of topical interaction
let's say contact dermatitis
got in contact with
poison iv um china you know
metal allergies for example
but also you can get a
reaction from that and a
measurable reaction and this
is a good way for us to detect
microbes for example we
inject you can inject the
protein purotony derivative
the tuberculin test or
the skin test or the ppd
test and detect the presence
or if the person has been
exposed to mycobacteria
you can also do it for for
fungal infections and other
infections like leishmania
candida so we can do
fungal skin tests and look
for type 4 hypersensitivity
and use that
particular reaction
to detect these or survey even
these type of
pathogens in a given
population so it's
important tool so to speak
let's talk a little
bit about immunological
memory because it's an
important concept Now
we spoke about the role
of memory T cells and
these are really
important cells and they
seem to also provide us
with lasting immunity.
Their importance,
how they work,
and the role of immunity is
still under investigation.
But classically we always
looked at immunological
memory as in the
presence of antibodies.
This is again not a
complete picture because as
we just discussed and i
want you to understand
that and because as we
discussed we there's also
t memory cells that's
important for example when
people are discussing
whether or not somebody has
memory let's say or develop
memory after they have
covet because a lot of times
when we measure that memory
is we measure whether or
not they have antibodies
so that's not the whole
picture so it's important
to realize that anyway um
immunological memory is
can be resolved from prior
exposure to the antigen.
That is referred to as the
primary immune response.
So then the secondary immune
response develops
the memory now.
So as we talked before,
when a B cell encounter
antigen for the first
time, they differentiate
the plasma cells with
the help of TH2 or TH17,
and then but then some of
these plasma cells become
memory cells. So it's
important to remember
that it's for half
distinction between the two.
So the primary immune
response usually
takes longer time
typically two weeks
before we reach peak
antibody formation.
On the other hand the
secondary immune response is
almost instant because of
the presence of memory cells
and this is the goal of
vaccination right there is
to induce the primary
response so that when you
encounter the antigen again
you don't have to wait two
weeks to develop the response
you're already ready to
go in many cases you can
block injury of the pathogen
even at the get-go at the
mucous membrane before
they arrive now there's also
isotype switching in this
particular instance so
with the primary response
you start out with the igm
isotype and then you switch
to igg with the secondary
immune response it's
immediately idg and you're
ready to go um one thing to
note here just something
that's interesting and it's
kind of important that b
cells do what these cells
do as they interact an
antigen or an epitome of an
antigen over time they
undergo what's called affinity
maturation what that means
is the antigens will start
selecting for the uh for
the antibodies that combine
the best. And this is
usually created by the actual
presence of hyper mutations
in the genes that code
for the antibodies, those
VHVL genes. So over time,
the antibodies that we make
become better and better
and better and binding
with the epitope on the
antigen with more affinity.
That's what you want.
You don't want a very
weak binding, because weak
binding does not elicit a
good immune response. But
again, this only happens
during the secondary and
as time goes by, which
is why our initial human
immune response is typically
not a very strong one.
Let's discuss a little
bit immunoregulation
because this is a very
important topic. We have kind
of talked about these
concepts here and there,
but let's try to summarize
them here in one place.
We've talked about the
concept of tolerance.
We will have a
lecture especially that
discusses tolerance and
autoimmunity which is a
really important topic
again one of the things
that can induce tolerance
in cells is for example
especially in t cells and
cause what's called energy
is the absence of the cg28
b7 cost immature signal
so the absence of that
signal can trigger energy
but there's other things
that can do that and
there'll be a lecture For
example, it is absence of a
stimulatory cytokine, etc.
Also, let's not forget a very
important role of
T-regulatory cells.
T-regulatory cells are
actually subtype of T-helper
cells that specifically
suppress the immune system.
These can be called
actually T-suppressors.
We no longer use that
term because we realize
they do more than
just suppression. They
actually can, they really
help with regulation.
They are CD4-positive,
like they're T-helfer
cells, but the only way
to really distinguish
them from other T
-helfer cells is by the
presence of the CD25
and expression of a
transcription factor,
specifically called FOXP3.
That's really the only
way to push them out.
There's also CD8-positive
or T-cytotoxic spacer
cells, which can help
prevent graft rejection
and can help prevent our
own body from attacking
itself, formation of
autoimmune diseases. So
these combination of many
mechanisms and this is
just a really brief
introduction guys to this
can help us with tolerance
and tolerating our
self-antigens and not have
the immune system just
go haywire. Again there'll
be a lecture on this.
We also talked about how
how the different cells,
Th1, Th2, and Th17, can
inhibit each other in a new
response by basically using
their signature cytokine.
So, for example, TNF gamma
that's produced by Th1
inhibits the other, Th2,
and Th17, and so on. So
that's a very important way,
that way you don't have all
of these cells dominating.
But do keep in mind that
this is dynamic. At some
point, for example a th1
response may dominate but
then it can regress and a
th2 then dominates or th17
okay um we already
discussed that th17 is
by definition a pro
-inflammatory type of
response that seems to
be damaging but you know
understanding that
information for example
we've been able to
identify il-70 which is the
signature cytokine of that
cell as being involved
in conditions that
are psoriasis, and if
you block IL-70, it can
actually help patients.
And so the more we
understand these
mechanisms, how
they're used, so we can
regulate it, we can
help a lot of patients
that have both autoimmune
and inflammatory diseases
that are caused by
the malfunction,
so to speak, of
the immune system.
This slide shows different
types of adaptive e-responses
involved of clearances
of different antigens.
It's kind of a summary for
you, but it's a pretty good
one. It just shows you, for
example, like neutralizing
antibodies can be used
to neutralize viruses,
bacteria, whether it's
intercellular or extracelular,
protozoans, whether
they are intercellular
or extracelular,
but don't seem to
work at all against
fungi and worms.
The hemoglobin
response in general
doesn't seem to work
at all with fungi.
At the same time, it
shows you that the cell
-mediated immune response
or the toxic T cells
are very effective against
viruses because they
are intercellular and
intercellular bacteria.
It also shows that
complement and obstinization
are very good at tackling
excellular bacteria.
Complement can also
be good at taking
out specifically
enveloped viruses.
So this is a good
just summary for
you for your own
information. So
in summary, we have
discussed the adaptive immune
response in this two
-type, two-part lecture.
Predominantly talked about
immunoglobulin structure,
function, the different types
as for isotypes, and how
are they involved in the
type 1, type 2, and type 3
hypersensitivities, which
are antibody-mediated. We
talked about different
important molecules, MSC class
1 and 2, discussed T-cell
receptor structure and
function, interaction,
associated receptors, its role in
immunological synapse, We
talked about the B-cell
receptor, its structure, which
is basically IGT, antibody,
and its function in important
recognizing antigens.
We talked about how T-cells,
even besides specifically
helper cells and different
kinds, are activated
and also how B-cells are
activated. We talked about
both the humanoidal and the
cell-mediated immune response
and the different subtypes
of T-helper cells 1,
2, and 17. We discussed at
the end immunological memory
and the importance of a
secondary immune response
and role of B cells
in that, and talked
a little briefly
about T memory cells.
And we also talked about immune
regulation and how
tolerance is important.
And at the end, I just
introduce you to a
clinical case, which we
will follow up in the
office hour and discuss
it more together.